so while North American League of
Legends might be in the offseason the
drama just doesn't stop coming what
started off as outrage over a potential
conflict of interest has turned into a
shitstorm a holy war that has TSM
members dropping twit longers left right
and center and dire docks career pretty
much sideswiped this is a total mess
[Music]
alright guys this is the part of the
video where I would usually tell you to
subscribe to the score eSports YouTube
channel and you should definitely still
do that if you haven't already but did
you know that we are fairly regularly
now streaming live on Twitch
go to twitch.tv slash the score you
sports and give us a follow you won't
regret it
okay so in case you've been living under
a Krug lately doublelift and TSM are
currently at the center of a vortex of
drama in the League of Legends world now
really this whole thing actually starts
at the beginning of this year and the
beginning of the LCS spring split you
see doublelift is playing his fifth
split for Team Liquid he's won for LCS
Championships back-to-back
he starts spring and he just totally
shits the bed Oh baby that's the setup
only his body of work this split he is
probably the worst ad carry in the
league right now which is so inexcusable
from from a player criticism for double
lips play comes in hot and heavy for his
part he says he's lost motivation to
continue competing at a high level he
gets sick he gets benched and all of a
sudden he says oh hold on I've got my
motivation back well too little too late
after two and a half years at doublelift
gets booted off Team Liquid and ends up
on TSM the prodigal son returns did you
shower mm-hmm your change I have
something better for you oh thanks
[Music]
the problem well doublelift happens to
be in a romantic relationship with tsm's
president Lena Xue now why exactly is
this a problem well as everyone has
pointed out numerous times now it does
present the potential for a conflict of
interest meaning doublelift could in
theory get preferential treatment from
the org because of his relationship with
someone in power in theory he could be
privy to information that other players
normally wouldn't be and basically just
business and pleasure would mix in
inappropriate ways now if you do want to
go a little bit more in depth on the
conflict of interest stuff and the
roster shuffle situation in general well
we made a whole video about that a few
weeks ago so go ahead and check that out
now if it wasn't for recent events I
probably would have sat here telling you
that although these concerns are
absolutely valid that Reddit and Twitter
would be overreacting just a little bit
except that mere weeks after double if
signed with TSM theory became reality on
Monday this happened this guy was maybe
a mistake that is double live stream and
that's Lina in the background saying
quote it's not up to me for example no
one wants to pick up da rock end quote
in one 10 second twitch clip the [ __ ]
completely hit the fan for TSM for
doublelift
and for Lina's ooh not to mention dyrdek
whose trade value it has to be said has
been seriously damaged by this entire
situation now after the stream twit
longers came in quickly with both
president lina zoo and TSM founder and
eid in publishing apologies the next day
the problem is they both kind of miss
the mark Lina's unfortunately is a
little bit self-serving and misses the
mark entirely when it comes to the
actual problem in it she says quote at
the end of the day no one feels worse
about this situation than I do and it's
already difficult enough to be a TSM fan
in these trying times I mean I don't
know maybe dar doc feels worse than you
she ends her apology by saying quote and
at the end of the day this mistake is
100% my fault and I wish the best for
Josh despite everything that happened
today this is just such a strangely
worded apology it's almost as if dar doc
did something wrong and she's absolving
him of it saying well despite what
happened you know I wish Josh the best
honestly it would have been really
prudent if a public relations or
communication specialist took a look at
this before they published it now Andy
dins is a little better sure it's
quintuple the size of Lina's and it
attempts to tackle all of the different
issues wrapped up here in a more
meaningful way but you would expect that
from the founder of the orb he comes
right out the gate by saying in no
uncertain terms
TSM [ __ ] up okay good then he says he
reached out to dart off personally and
is going to make things right with him
good some actual action guys twit
longers don't actually mean [ __ ] in real
life they don't do anything to fix
problems you have to take real actions
not tweet about but he also tries to
distance Lina's position from League of
Legends operations which is honestly
from an outsider looking in kind of a
hard pill to swallow considering we just
over her
Leyna talking about dyrdek situation and
in her own apology she goes into detail
about you know whether he was gonna go
down to Academy or share time or find a
new team and Eden the founder of GSM
Reggie if you like goes on to say quote
I thought there was enough and there
still is enough distance surrounding
their working relationship that I am
comfortable with their roles end quote
now it's hard not to ask after reading
that how can he be comfortable with
their working relationship when just a
few paragraphs later he calls Lina's
handling of the dark situation quote
disappointing but neither apology
addresses the real issue here the fact
that Lina and double if obviously are
not acting in a professional manner when
it comes to their relationship at work
and now personally guys I do not think
it's reasonable to say TSM can't pick up
doublelift because he's dating the
president look he sports is not a big
place the LCS is really not a big place
these things are going to come up from
time to time I mean human beings tend to
get together romantically that's what we
do it's kind of like our thing as a
species those of you out there who in
your own lives are doing a 9 to 5 thing
you're in your careers you already know
that workplace relationships can and do
happen and as far as I'm concerned it is
none of our damn business what these two
individuals do when they're not at work
however I do think it's reasonable for
all of us to expect the highest level of
professionalism from these two
individuals when they're at work so what
does that mean well for starters it
means taking confidential calls in
private it means treating each other as
work colleagues first and romantic
partners second when you're on TSM time
it means not interacting with each other
two differently than you would if you
weren't dating the person despite what's
been posted on reddit the core issue
here has nothing to do with double ifs
Lenovo PC or as OBS settings it isn't
about Lina having a confidential call
while he's streaming
it's about her having a confidential
call while he's in the same room it's
not just bad that we heard it it's bad
that he hurt now a quick word about dar
doc here who obviously is actually the
victim in this entire dramatic series of
events his trade value wasn't just
damaged by what we overheard Lina saying
it's been damaged by the peripheral
information that's come out of the
woodwork as a result of this scandal the
entire narrative that's been pushed on
us for the last little while about how
dar doc has evolved reached his final
form how he's gone beyond those sort of
more toxic days of years past has been
challenged by stuff like what locodoco
said in a recent video our dog has been
a troublesome part of the TFM roster
from the start in the first few weeks of
practice there was a big blowup from dar
talked and talked fur hat and TSM and
dar doc both thought things would get
better but throughout the season there
have been constant problems and the
sport psyche has been working directly
with and way more food on any other
player and the results have been pretty
middlee now could all that be known and
understood knowledge within the LCS
ownership community absolutely but it's
still damaging to dar Doc's value as a
player to have it come out to the public
now another thing that's been brought up
several times is the LCS Players
Association and the fact that doublelift
bjergsen and bio frost are all on it and
they're all on TSM and bjergsen is a
part owner in TSM now now that is indeed
a little worrying and I think we'd all
like to see at least a few of them step
down from those positions to make room
for a more diverse group of players but
what I also want you to understand is
for all intents and purposes the LCS
Players Association isn't particularly
powerful their own stated goal after all
is to provide quote
access to information Council and the
opportunity to voice feedback and enact
change in quote remember we are talking
about League of Legends here it's an
eSports space where Riot the game
publisher basically has total control
over the ecosystem there's only so much
of players association is going to be
able to do it's not like a player's
union in
ba or the MLB or anything like that as
for where we go from here well we need
to see at least two things from TSM
pronto
number one they need to make sure that
DAR doc is taken care of they owe it to
him to make sure that he finds a new
home that he's satisfied with after
basically torpedoing his trade value and
number two we need to see some clear
measurable and above all transparent
changes in TSM's organizational
structure for starters how about a set
of guidelines that govern employee
behavior in situations like these one
thing we don't need to do guys is go on
a witch-hunt against a president who
clearly excels at her job but made a
serious error in judgment in this
particular case
TSM took the El here and they absolutely
deserve to get blasted for it but what's
done is done
let's see how we can fix the problem one
of the less esoteric pieces but
something important nonetheless which is
Who Framed Roger Rabbit now this is one
of my favorite films of all time they're
now a little piece of trivia for you
legend goes that Tim Curry was supposed
to play the role of judge doom two hours
late oh really kind of layers to this
movie it's deep dude